latest covid wave has rampaged through
rural parts of america including the
great state of montana where coveted
related hospitalizations have hit an
all-time high this in a state where just
57 percent of eligible people are
vaccinated our meg oliver has the story
of one patient in intensive care and a
family that is trying to give her
strength
oh my gosh
pam lee fights back tears as her 35 year
old daughter hillary tries to wave
through the window i love you too
after months of waiting the restaurant
manager with no health issues was
planning to get the vaccine when she got
covered within two weeks she was on a
ventilator i was a nurse for over 40
years
and so i knew this could happen
i was praying it never would but here we
are
how does her prognosis look
i can't even go there
i can't even go there she's only alive
because of this machine i don't know why
people aren't more scared of what we're
seeing every day with this dr jamie
belski is vice chair of the emergency
department at billings clinic she says
if the number of patients does not start
to fall the hospital will have to
consider rationing care
how do you get more people vaccinated to
stop this they have to spread the word
one of dr belski's former patients is
helping her get the word out when i saw
you two weeks ago you could barely
breathe
oh i know we met 59 year old frank
miller in september after a long battle
with kovid 19 which compromised his
motor skills now in a rehab center
he's learning how to walk and eat again
i would advise that maybe everybody
should go and get the shop meanwhile
patients like lee are fighting to
survive
hillary your mom is up there when you
look at her what do you think
i can't even think
it's just painful to watch
and these things can be prevented
painful to watch it's very painful
the leaves wanted to talk to us to let
us know when hillary got kovid she spent
the first 10 days calling all her
unvaccinated friends urging them to get
the shot her family can only hope it's
not too late for her nate
meg thank you we've seen this story time
and time again it's happening more often
yes but did you hear what you just said
this can be prevented that's why this is
so frustrating and heartbreaking and you
just don't want families to have to go
through this or to get this serious
before you realize i should have gotten
a vaccine the only people are getting
really sick
and keep in mind this young woman is 35
with no health issues and now she's on a
ventilator fighting literally fighting
for her life reach yeah you're right
imagine being on the other end of that
call yeah she's sitting in the hospital
and calling her loved ones and friends
yes saying you can do something about
this and prevent this from happening
please do yeah no doubt about